so we're used to
seeing these creepy disturbing teachers
and all content related to that but this
one picked up by libs of tick tock may
still shock you i want to put this tweet
up on the screen
so you can see the um
the screenshot hold on let me pull it
myself okay so
listed tick tock reports male teacher
writes about how good it feels wearing
women's undergarments to school and
coming out as non-binary to his students
and then we have a male teacher here and
here's the picture that he posted online
and he has his own caption says so this
is me feeling my best teacher self
because i'm wearing panties on a work
day for the first time ever and i feel
so good
um id a tall bearded demi boy with
pomaded hair and glasses wearing a
purple and white checked shirt a gray
sweater vest and a brown tweed jacket
with black jeans
and then he continues i signed up to
lead an affinity group for lgbtqia plus
students at my school a while back the
first meeting is this afternoon and i'm
going to be coming out to a bunch of
high schoolers as bi and nb
the hell is n b
n o n like n b non-binary n b
okay i'm a bit nervous good vibe slash
encouragement are needed and welcome
and then there's another
follow-up that libra tick tock has
this is from last year march of last
year uh where he's wearing addresses
first ever dress feels very teachery
please be kind
and then he identifies himself as a demi
boy again and if you're wondering what a
demi boy is
i had to google that and it says
an identity that describes someone who
identifies with both male and agender
genders
what the hell is agender
okay now you gotta look that up it's
just like
once you start peeling back these onions
you you know you you immediately regret
it but so agender is
an identity that does describe somebody
without gender or who does not relate to
either binary
to either binary gender
okay
so uh a demi boy quote-unquote is
someone who identifies as having a
gender and also not having one at the
same time
which just does that doesn't mean
anything at all
you know what it means
here's what all that means because
that's total nonsense okay
absolute nonsense
what it actually means for this creep
is that he has a fetish
for wearing women's underwear
around kids
and this is the label that he puts on it
to make it sound you know like something
we have to affirm and include and accept
that's what that really means in his
case
so this is a this is a teacher
announcing
that it feels good wearing women's
underwear
wearing panties
to school
that he's gonna he's gonna come out to
his students
like if we were to do a poll
you know we'd take this
show this to
every parent in the country with kids in
public school
um and pull all of them
what percentage do you think
would say that yeah this is the kind of
thing they want their teachers doing
like what percentage of those parents
would be excited about the idea
of of a male teacher in his panties who
wears them because he says it makes him
feel good and sitting down and coming
out and to his to his students and
having a sexual conversation like what
percentage if we were to pull every
single public school parent what
percentage would say oh yeah that's
great that's like that's exactly what i
i'm hoping is is happening
this is why i send my kid to school
would we get up to like point one
percent would we even make it that high
i really don't think we would
which is why it's so important to keep
as we talked about turn on all the
lights
and when you turn on the lights you're
gonna see a lot of things you don't want
to see
but we have to see them
because here's the other thing that we
have to keep we have to remember here is
that um
if we don't if we don't see it you know
if we allow these things to happen in
darkness our kids are still being
subjected to it hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated